hello and welcome to the chicky science
show where in this video we're going to
address the question
is aging contagious now i know what
you're probably thinking
of course it's not contagious visiting
my older relatives won't make me age
faster
and yeah fine crap but that isn't what
i'm going to talk about in this video
so before you click away i am still
going to address the question
is aging contagious but on a different
scale
because instead of looking at it between
individuals we'll be looking at this in
the context of within
an individual which will probably make
it an even more entertaining and
interesting video
so before i go any further i just want
to say that this idea for this video
came from when i
recently just read this nature aging
review article
asynchronous contagious and digital
agent which if you can have access to it
was a very interesting read so i do
recommend it and so you'll see one of
their sections was talking about is
agent contagious
and so i thought you know what this
sounds like a really interesting topic
i'll explore it a little bit further so
here we are
so let's get going is aging contagious
so what i really mean by this question
is does the aging of one individual cell
affect the age of another cell
and more from that does the aging of one
tissue affect the aging of other tissues
within our bodies
see told you it was interesting so one
of the reasons why we'd want to
maybe address this question and
understand the answers
is due to the fact that there's been a
lot of research now that seems to
suggest that
aging isn't just a linear process and
instead it seems to be asynchronous
for example in humans the cardiovascular
system
exhibits a much greater functional
decline with age than the
gastrointestinal system
and the same goes for different muscle
organisms different tissues seem to age
at different rates
and it can even be seen within a species
for example in one human study
they defined so-called agiotypes so that
they could take into account
the fact that tissues that age most
rapidly differ from one person to
another
and the second reason that we might want
to be able to address the question
is aging contagious comes to the fact
that it may help us
better understand how to be able to
prevent aging and age-associated
so for the remainder of this video we'll
first be looking at the evidence that
seems to support the fact that aging is
contagious
and also try and throw in a couple of
ideas where aging might not be
considered contagious
and then at the end given our conclusion
as to whether or not aging really is
contagious we'll say what does that
really mean for prevention
and how that might impact future work so
first then in terms of examples
the best example as suggested in this
review article
is cellular senescence and so cellulosin
essence which i feel like i've spoken
about so many times now on this channel
is characterized by two key
characteristics firstly it's a cell
cycle arrest so the cells stop dividing
and the second feature of senescent
cells is its senescence
secretory phenotype referred to as the
sasp and as suggested by its name
is a secretory phenotype that includes a
variety of different inflammatory
factors
and the current idea is that these
inflammatory factors
help to bring in immune cells that can
clear the senescent cells
however if the senescent cell doesn't
get cleared the sas continues which
could result in chronic inflammation
or has often been referred to as
inflammation and this association of
senescent cells with age
is supported by the fact that senescent
cells seem to accumulate with age and
studies dynamised have shown that the
clearance of senescent cells
promotes their health span but more
specifically there is evidence that
seems to support the fact that senescent
cells
and their secretory phenotype may be
demonstrating how aging can be
contagious
here in the context of one senate cell
being able to induce
another neighbouring cell to also enter
senescence
and this is more formally referred to as
paracrine senescence
with the paracrine signaling referring
to cell to cell communication
whereby one cell can produce a signal
that alters the behavior of a nearby
cell
so in this case you've got senescent
cells secreting these inflammatory
factors
and other signaling molecules and these
factors can be sensed
by cells in its proximity and also
altered that cell's behavior
and so as demonstrated in this nature
cell biology paper
they identified that oncogene essence in
a cell
can cause paracrine senescence in vivo
and they also identified
multiple factors within this asp that
might be responsible
this included factors of the tgf beta
family
as well as the chemokine ccl2 and ccl20
however this is still an area that's
heavily being explored and in many ways
it is quite challenging to try and
understand
these non-cell autonomous interactions
but this is only senescence-inducing
senescence
what about the other hallmarks of aging
well it's very interesting but
i asked that question because i actually
made a video last year that looked at
the relationship between
alzheimer's disease and celiac
senescence whereby there seems to be a
chicken and the egg scenario
whereby it's not sure if the pathology
that underpins alzheimer's disease
that is the protein aggregation of two
proteins
tau and amyloid beta and the fact that
there's also senescent cells
and non-urinal cells including
astrocytes and microglia
and so the question that seems very much
unanswered is are the senescent cells
causing these proteins to aggregate or
is it the presence of these protein
aggregates that are causing a cell to
enter senescence
and so either way whichever mechanism
appears to be the correct one or if both
of them are at
play both of them do support the fact
that aging is contagious
whereby one offense can trigger a
subsequent offense
and one of the reasons why this is such
a complicated question
is due to the fact that alzheimer's
disease like other neurodegenerative
diseases
are often referred to as protein folding
diseases
because their pathology is associated
with protein aggregates
tau and amyloid beta as i mentioned with
alzheimer's and
alpha-synuclein and parkinson's disease
and so whilst initially
protein aggregates in these diseases
were thought of as a cell intrinsic
phenomenon
whereby one cell accumulates the
aggregates and becomes dysfunctional
based on the pathology it now seems that
these diseases can spread to other
regions of the brain
and the interesting thing about this
potential protein aggregate spreading is
that it's very similar to the biology of
prion proteins
which are proteins that are actually
contagious whereby
one misfolded protein can cause other
proteins
to also become misfolded and in fact
amyloid beta tau and alpha-synuclein
have been referred to as prion proteins
anyway so far these examples have only
really taken into account
proximity in terms of aging being
contagious
we also need to take into account the
big picture
and i literally mean big i send the
brain immune guards axes
i'm pretty happy with that subway anyway
i've been meaning to make a video on
this for a long time and i probably
still will at some point so i'm not
really going to talk about it too much
here
but effectively what the big axis refers
to is the fact that there's
communication between the guts the brain
and the immune system
and part of this is actually due to the
fact that millions of neurons
and immune cells are actually converging
in the gastrointestinal tract
but also the fact that these signals go
both ways
so the brain can communicate with the
gut but the guts due to the presence of
different
hormones and food products can also
communicate with
the brain and this also takes into
account the microbiome
and dysbiosis of the microbiome has been
associated with a variety of
different age-associated diseases as i
mentioned in my previous video
and so this really is a big topic
but the important point that i want to
make is that we heavily depend
on the system to function normally and
communication between cells in proximity
and also systemically
it's so important for the regulation of
a variety of different biological
processes that are going on within our
bodies
and so the scary thing is that our
amazing bodies and our amazing system is
also our greatest flaw
in that dysfunction of one tissue or one
cell
can have the adverse consequence of
disrupting other tissues
and so this leads me on to what does
this mean for prevention
well one kind of obvious point is the
fact that if aging is contagious
it kind of escalates and kind of
snowballs in its magnitude over time
and so starting earlier would be kind of
the more optimal thing to do
however we don't know what this optimal
time necessarily is at the moment
given the fact that rates of aging
differ between different individuals
and so likely prevention options would
do too and secondly it seems to suggest
that
due to the fact that one tissue may be
causing aging and other tissues
means that multiple strategies might be
required another interesting point to
make is the fact that if aging is
contagious
one way to prevent aging is to stop the
spreading and so to do that you really
need to understand
the communication systems in which the
aging is spreading
and then in this case we would actually
want to shoot the messenger
anyway there are two main routes of
communication one is neuronal
communication so electrical signals
between neurons
and the second one is communication
within our blood circulation
and in fact this kind of comes into play
with the landmark 2005 paper that came
from the comboy lab
whereby they joined the circulatory
systems of young and old mice
so called heterochronic parabiosis and
the remarkable thing was that
the old mice displayed regenerative
properties of their muscle and liver
just by being exposed to the serum of
younger animals
again this is a topic that i hope to
cover in a bit more detail
at some point in the future so with that
i feel like i've given you the answer to
is aging contagious
i know i did say i try and find some
evidence against this but
i just don't think i have anything
strong enough to say so
yes i think aging at least within an
individual
can be considered contagious and that's
due to the inherent need and requirement
for cells to be able to communicate
with each other and their environment
but i think understanding this process
and taking it into account will help us
better understand the aging process
and ways of preventing aging so with
that i want to give a thank you to my
patreon supporters
and as always thank you for listening
you